if you want to learn more about cyber  security the all access plan will let  you choose what  when and how you want to learn  with this plan you'll get complete  access to all seven courses in the  advanced cyber security program for one  full year  all for the same tuition as six  individual courses  you can view all course materials  including video lectures assignments and  exams and you can get answers to your  questions about coursework and  assignments from stanford teaching  assistants  with the all access plan you can move  freely in and out of each course  visiting and revisiting content at your  own pace  and when you successfully complete any  six courses in the program  you'll earn a stanford certificate of  achievement in advanced cybersecurity  enroll now in the all access plan to get  great value with access to the entire  advanced cyber security program for one  full year